[Music]
Angelina Jolie candidly addresses her
split from Brad Pitt the stunning
actress covers the September issue of
Vanity Fair her interview is open honest
candid and very vulnerable she tells the
mag of her divorce from Brad quote it's
just been the hardest time and were just
kind of coming up for air we're all
trying to do our best to heal our family
the former couple's decision to call it
quits shocked the world they had been
together more than ten years and things
turned ugly fast courts got involved and
rumors swirled still Angelina says she
and Brad are now on the same page quote
we care for each other and care about
our family and we are both working
towards the same goal it's clear that
their six children are the main focus
since the split Angelina says she's
worked hard to be a really good
homemaker she picks up dog poop clean
dishes and reads bedtime stories
she explained quote I was very worried
about my mother growing up a lot I do
not want my children to be worried about
me Angelina even bravely admitted she
cries in the shower not in front of the
kids
quote do they need to know that
everything's going to be all right even
when you're not sure it is up next for
the actress the release of first they
killed my father
the thriller she co-produced with her
son Maddox and also positive Angelina
revealed she and her estranged father
Jon Voight have reconciled
[Music]